[Musique]
c'est un service mythique qui tire sa
révérence quatrième top il sera 10
heures 19 minutes l'horloge parlante
depuis 1933 elle donne l'heure aux
Français en échange d'un coup de fil
tout a commencé ici à l'Observatoire de
Paris où le dispositif est soigneusement
gardé dans les sous-sols les annonces
parlées sont enregistrées sur pellicule
comme le son d'un film et enrouler sur
ce cylindre
sur le cylindre trois lecteurs heure
minute seconde à l'origine de la
première horloge parlante au monde
l'astronome Ernest Esclangon et derrière
la toute première voie cet homme au
quatrième top il sera exactement 0 heure
0 minute comment est-il été choisi
réponse en 1962 la maison d'horlogerie
qui a conçu cette pendule qui l'a
construite et qu'il a réalisé est venu
me chercher parce qu'à ce moment là je
m'appelais monsieur Radiolo j'étais
aperçoit excuse-moi de dire ça je ne
suis pas pétant enfin tout de même c'est
pour cela qu'on m'a un début de me
chercher trois ans plus tard en 1965 le
dispositif se modernise c'est une
horloge atomique plus moderne et plus
performante
voici cette nouvelle horloge qu'est-ce
qu'il a différencie de la vieille
surtout les commander par un système
électronique plus simple et plus précis
et puis comme vous pouvez voir les
beaucoup plus simple du point de vue
mécanique qui dit nouvelle horloge
parlante dit nouvelle voix l'acteur
Pierre Lauret remplace Marcel Laporte
que c'est au tour d'un postier anonyme
d'être la voix emblématique
17h44 minutes 30 secondes et les voix de
femme alors il faut attendre 1991 pour
que ça change le système devient
électronique la comédienne Marie
sylvieber et choisit la jeune femme a
enregistré des années d'avance d'horloge
parlante
au moment de l'enregistrement ce qui m'a
semblé très étrange c'est de dire
mercredi 18 septembre 2088 au 4e top il
sera 12h parce que je savais que je ne
serai plus là c'était comme un
rendez-vous que je me donnais que je ne
pouvais pas tenir depuis 2005 le service
est payant un euro 50 la pelle à partir
du 1er juillet 2022 il ne sera plus
possible d'appeler le 36 69 l'horloge
par l'entracroche en cause notamment la
baisse du nombre d'appels depuis le
début des années 2000